all right let's get into this week's
mailbag you can email info
davidpakman.com
and many of you do um let's go through
some emails that i received some
interesting ideas thoughts all sorts of
different things all right first message
today is from bryce
bryce um is thinking like a um
expert on cults quite frankly and bryce
says david is it just me or when trump
eventually passes away all the trump
supporters will be acting like he's
going to come back and resurrect like
jesus what are your thoughts uh that's
bryce from from new york
yeah i mean listen there's no question
that there are many cult-like elements
surrounding donald trump
and he is seen almost as a pseudo deity
as a as a demigod by some of his
followers and when trump famously said i
could shoot people on fifth avenue and
not lose support he was
latching on to something very real which
is that for many of his followers the
facts don't really matter it's the idea
of trump that they care about now
when trump eventually passes away
will people literally think he's going
to resurrect like jesus that's probably
a little bit of an exaggeration but not
that by that much i do think that he
will be deified in death by
whoever is still with him at that time
um you know people are still flying look
i mean just drive around in most parts
of the country you can still find some
trump 2020 flags which might even have
something added on to it like biden lost
or now let's go brandon or something
like that um
they are still deifying him in a sense
in life and i expect them to in death
literal resurrection ideology
probably not that's probably a little
too far
but
it's trump it's trump so maybe i
wouldn't ever assume the answer is uh
the answer is impossible
justin wrote to me and said microchips
are real
sir david does no one else see the
connection the reason why there are
microchip shortages for new vehicles
is that they were all used in the
production of the vaccines which with
much respect justin yeah i know justin's
kidding
and there is this funny way sometimes
it's funny sometimes it's not funny when
different conspiracy theories or
different data points come together to
foment a conspiracy theory this one's
kind of funnier we have a microchip
shortage for cars because all the
microchips are in the vaccines that okay
this one's just funny the one that's not
so funny though is the one we looked at
on monday of someone speaking at some
school board meeting and explaining that
what ties all of this stuff together who
profits from the vaccines
uh who controls the deep state all of
this different it's the jews and that
was one woman beautifully tying together
in her mind
disgustingly in reality but beautifully
in her mind tying together all of these
different conspiracy theories and saying
the jews are responsible for all this
stuff we knew that it was happening
because of reports we saw it happen very
very real in a real way over the weekend
next email is from alan
allen says in response to my video about
are there really any anti-vaccine
religions alan said you overlooked an
important point on religious vaccine
exemptions alan says david sir i heard
your segment on religious exemptions for
vaccines and although you did a great
job analyzing the situation i think
there's an important aspect you
overlooked
i was teaching at a catholic high school
until the end of last year now i'm in a
public school thankfully and the biggest
debate was on the morality of how the
vaccines were developed and not that
vaccination is specifically against the
religion what i'm referring to is the
cell lines of aborted fetuses used in
development of the vaccines although we
had a decent percentage of our community
staff students and families get
vaccinated we had multiple people
hesitant or objecting because of the
cell line usage again this is not
explicitly the catholic faith saying the
members are forbidden from getting
vaccinated but it does introduce a lot
of hesitancy which i'm sure exists
through most throughout most christian
faiths love your show alan yeah a few
people emailed me about this and this is
a good point which is my discussion last
week was about
is there actually a religion that is
just against vaccination there are
individuals who are saying because i am
against abortion and because
fetal cell lines were used in the
development of the vaccines and the
technology even though there are not
fetal cells in the injection
that
is being used by some but it's
i did miss it i should have mentioned it
i agree
but it's different than the question of
simply
it's against my religion because that
seems to allude more
to the specific teachings of religion
about vaccines and i think i should have
mentioned it i'm glad that people
emailed it about it
gareth rhoden
this is actually an important topic
gareth says
very suspect florida numbers hey david
and the crew do the florida numbers not
seem incredibly low considering the case
rate is almost 1500
yet only one death per day i've attached
a photo and the photo is exactly what
gareth describes so there's two things
going on in florida one of them i've
talked about in florida they've done
this thing
where they report the deaths on a delay
so each week they report the deaths from
the previous week
and so it always makes it look like over
the last seven or eight days
deaths have just declined almost to zero
but it's been going on for months like
for months if you look at the recent
deaths it looks like the last seven days
are almost zero then they update it and
then it shows up again so that's that's
one part of it
i also more generally though
am wondering whether florida is just
lying or not fully reporting or not
collecting not collecting would be the
most
sort of realistic explanation because
the numbers just look bizarrely low
relative to what's going on in other
states we're seeing case declines in the
united states but even the numbers more
generally in florida after the seven day
kind of like holding period
um it it looks weird it looks weird so i
think if we're going to say
florida is lying we really need evidence
but i think that what we could suspect
is
given florida's lack of concern at the
governor's level
for controlling covid
and given desantis's lack of interest
in being particularly transparent we
know this based on that person who was
fired for putting together the covet
dashboard that more accurately reported
the data
it wouldn't be shocking if there's just
a sort of like ah we don't really care
about fully reporting not someone going
in and saying lie change these numbers
but
it wouldn't surprise me if there was
sort of like an indifference and there
wasn't full reporting currently going on
certainly possible
um tommy wrote to me about trump rallies
and said hi david i think you're going
to find this quite interesting yet every
time i see a trump rally i see the same
two people in the background one is a
black guy with a white shirt saying
blacks for trump and the guy beside
beside him is wearing a green shirt
veterans for trump now there's uh two
different rallies they're both behind
trump here are the photos by the way
love your show yet tommy is completely
right that veterans for trump i'm less
sure of
but we're seeing um uh some of the same
supposed blacks for trump supporters
show up at multiple rallies
my position on this is as follows
when you try to find information about
blacks for trump as a group there's
almost nothing on the internet there's
no you try to figure out who's
who are the members who's in charge what
is the group what exactly do they do
you find essentially nothing so the
reaction for many is this is a fake
group
and the campaign is paying black people
to stand behind trump during rallies to
make it seem like he has black support
now i've stopped short of saying that
because i don't know that to be true
and for me it feels a little weird to
basically say
a movement of minority folks
claiming to have a particular position
is by definition astroturf or fake
unless i have real evidence that that's
what's going on i'm not comfortable
saying that it feels weird to me
but in terms of data points we do know
that the group blacks for trump has
almost no footprint
online which is strange in 2021
that there are times where it's seen
it's been alleged that
uh trump-affiliated groups have been
recruiting what are essentially actors
people to stand holding signs at events
not saying they were recruiting black
folks specifically but we have that as a
data point and some of the same people
appear at multiple of these rallies so
that's what we know i'm not ready to say
it's all paid actors but we've gotten a
number of emails about this and it
certainly seems as though there may be
something to
it's not clear how real blacks for trump
is as an organization i'm completely
comfortable saying that next email is
from andrew and it's called covid the
new culture war
hello david says andrew i believe that
covid is the new culture war among
republicans such as the whole merry
christmas culture war when i didn't know
of anyone on the left who really cared
if somebody used merry christmas or
happy holidays at least the merry
christmas culture war wasn't deadly
as today's republicans have literally
entered into a death cult also i think
all these police officers quitting for
refusing the vaccine is a good thing
since the majority of them support trump
and as a result the police brutality
rate will most likely go down a few
people have actually emailed me that
saying aren't the cops quitting over the
vaccine thing exactly the cops that
we've been saying are the bad apples
that we want out anyway i don't know
that for sure
but it's a very interesting hypothesis
which is when we talk about police
brutality etc i believe we accurately
say it's a very small minority of bad
apples
which can spoil the bunch for sure
if there's overlap between the police
brutality people
and the cops refusing to get the vaccine
maybe we benefit from them quitting and
no longer being police officers it's a
hypothesis folks it's a hypothesis
that's all we're saying
terms of the the left doesn't really
care about merry christmas or happy
holidays
i i agree i've never met anyone who
expressed being angry about merry
christmas being said at a store what i
would always do without getting offended
just as like a kind of joke
is if someone said merry christmas to me
i would say happy hanukkah i wasn't mad
i didn't later complain it's just my
immediate reaction they're saying
something to me based on what they
celebrate so i resp i don't celebrate
christmas but i respond saying happy
hanukkah and if it's not relevant to
them maybe the next time they go oh
maybe i'll say happy holidays because
merry christmas might not be or it's
it's like no big deal i just kind of
found it funny it's how i entertain
myself at grocery stores uh but yeah
i've never met anyone who was like mad
or said i need to speak to the manager
someone said merry christmas it is a
trump top culture war uh for sure
okay last email today this is a
different one we had a lot of
substantive emails positive emails
questions comments this is mark mark
writes to me about garbage and says your
left wing garbage and propaganda is the
root or the root as some say of
everything wrong with our country you
have no business being on the air
you
are
garbage that is mark presented without
comment
as we get into what will hopefully be a
great weekend for everybody thanks for
joining me we've got a fantastic bonus
show planned for you and we will be back
next week with so much more
sign up at joinpacman.com get instant
access to today's bonus show otherwise
no more new content until monday when
we'll be back with our next show